I've heard this conversation a 100 times
in my life people say why do we only
have Thanksgiving dinner on Thanksgiving
of course and a lot of restaurants will
do a little take on Thanksgiving dinner
I've had a Thanksgiving dinner on a
sandwich stuffing is one of the greatest
things ever made ever and I wish I could
have stuffing every day of my life now
who stopping you you know what myself
why you know what it's unclear at this
point it's it's a very unhealthy dish
unfortunately very how about once a
month maybe I'd love it you're not doing
a stuffing once stuffing more than every
Thanksgiving you think at Cosby
Thanksgiving everyone's like is it the
turkey that's making us
tired or is it yeah it's like it's strip
toan Tri